here are some of the most common
mistakes nurses make whenever they start
IVs the first mistake is failing to
Anchor the vein so really anytime you
start IVs or even draw blood you want to
go and anchor that vein and the reason
you want to is because whenever you go
to insert by putting pressure on that
skin with that needle if that vein is
not secured it can just go to the side
we sometimes refer to that as a rolling
vein and to prevent that from happening
what you want to do is you want to take
your hand like this go below that
insertion SI and just simply hold
pressure just to keep that vein in place
while you poke it next is hitting vein
valves so in your veins you have these
little valves that prevent the back flow
of blood now how can you know if you're
going to hit a vein valve well look at
your patients's veins you can palpate
and you may feel this little naughty
region along the vein that could
indicate a valve or if your patient has
a low body fat percentage you can
actually see them visibly on the skin
like here so the problem with this is
whenever you actually go to hit the the
vein and you go to slide off the canula
you'll have difficulty sliding off that
canula and some nurses to prevent this
they try to float in the canula by
flushing as they Advance another mistake
is failing to advance that catheter once
you get blood return so it's extremely
exciting whenever you're starting an IV
and you get blood return cuz that tells
you you hit that vein but you're not
quite ready to advance that canula into
that vein just yet on the adult patient
what you want to do is once you get
blood return you want to slightly about
the width of a nickel insert that needle
just a little bit more into that vein
and then slide off that canula and it
should go in very easily the next is
using a tourniquet when you really
probably shouldn't use it so not all
situations whenever you're starting IV
require you to use a tourniquet some
patients when they have amazing veins
like this they're already visible at the
surface they literally look like huge
Nightcrawler worms underneath the skin
that you could just poke from across the
distance you wouldn't necessarily want
to use a tourniquet and the reason for
this is because you're going to be
putting a lot of pressure on that vein
and whenever you go to poke it think
about like a balloon concept if you went
and poked a balloon with a needle what's
going to happen it's going to pop and in
a sense that's what's going to happen to
that vein it's going to burst open
underneath the skin another thing is
using the wrong needle gauge when you're
starting IVs you want to look at that
vein that you're using and ask yourself
is this vein big enough to hold the side
of needle gauge that I'm going to
actually insert into it with IV supplies
it will tell you what size you have we
have 18 20 22 and so forth and with IVs
the smaller the number the larger the
gauge I know that's confusing but just
try to remember that so if you have an
itty bitty little vein and your patient
needs an 18 gauge you probably don't
want to stick that 18 gauge in that
little vein because it's not going to
hold it and it's going to collapse next
is using the wrong angle whenever you go
to insert that needle into the vein you
want to use about a 15 to 30° angle and
this is going to prevent you from
actually going straight through the vein
and not being able to advance your
canula and then finally failing to prep
your IV supplies so this really has
nothing to do with actually inserting
the IV but before you start an IV you
always want to make sure that you are
prepped and ready to go because you have
a limited amount of hands that you can
use to help you whenever you're actually
doing this procedure so whenever you
actually get blood return you're ready
to advance your limit like one hand and
then the other hand has to help assist
with everything so make sure that you
have everything completely set up your
flushes and everything for whenever
you're ready okay so that wraps up this
video and I actually have a live
demonstration of me starting an IV on a
patient so if you want to check that out
you can watch it up here